let's hear from you the people that make
this all possible without you i'm a guy
in a room with a mic and it's very very
sad let's first hear via discord
uh from alex from baltimore remember
that it is davidpakman.com discord
that's the place to go alex you're on
what's on your mind my friend
hey dave you can hear me yes i can
cool um
so i have a question about i guess
america in general
so especially if you listen to more
left news and opinion
it's basically the opinion that
amer pretty much america can't do
anything right everything about america
sucks
is that
is there anything that america is
actually still
better or the best in the world at
that's actually positive i don't mean
you know gun deaths and incarceration
numbers or anything like that
well listen i mean here i don't agree
who who has that perspective on the left
first of all well like well i guess no
one says it outright okay
who do you think believes it um
so i guess instead of
i guess it would be more i do i don't
want to throw other shows on play yeah
let me put in let's put a different i
think i have a good way to couch it
which is okay because the left wants
things to be so much better sometimes it
sounds like the left thinks the us is
much worse than the right like the us is
much more down on the us is that fair is
that kind of what you're saying
yeah kinda and i guess if you were to
consume so much of that news you it
would be easy to fall into that trap
right i was just curious is there
anything
that america is actually just as good if
not better than say western europe who
we're always comparing ourselves to
listen the us is by nature of being so
geographically large and diverse by
nature of having so many people and by
nature of having um uh so many
um different industries that are that
are possible in the country has so many
things that other countries would dream
of when it comes to
the you know so many of the best
universities in the world are in the us
so many of the best medical facilities
in the world are in the us when you look
at medical advancements so many come in
the united states technological culture
you know all these different things i
think there's no question about that i
think where the left chimes in and says
whoa hold on a second
is
that
someone like me a social democrat
believes
so much of the good that comes from
those things is reserved for a very
small slice of the population
and is uh not helping
such large swaths of the people in the
u.s but yeah without a doubt the the uh
i mean listen i could live somewhere
else but i choose to live in the united
states because there are a lot of great
things about the country and there's a
lot of things that need to be fixed
gotcha no that that's a good insight you
know that i i appreciate that i do have
a uh i like to ask you travel questions
i appreciate that you humor me on them
if that's all right with you sure
um
do you ever take into consideration the
the government in question when you
travel to a place for example i'm
getting into
the history of china
and i would love to go see their history
and culture but the ccp is
horrible do you do you ever consider
such things when you travel or should we
i do and i think i i do i consider it
and to say whether we should really
depends on the individual and and listen
alex i don't know what's making so much
noise in the background but it's crazy i
don't know if you're running some kind
of a uh you know hydraulic pump or
something
no a guy was uh driving by owner oh okay
so here's the thing sorry i consider it
at the end of the day if given the
opportunity
to go to like russia or china when
things settle down i would i would do it
because i want to learn about it it
doesn't mean i endorse the government
you know i've because my family's from
argentina i've traveled to argentina
during every government almost all of
which i am not a big fan of so yes i
consider it and i would factor it in but
ultimately it's up to every individual
to decide what am i getting out of this
versus am i tacitly supporting the
government by even going and it's a very
personal decision
right then china is a good example
because if you support a business you
are supporting the government because
they're so intertwined yes less so than
in the past
good questions alex i appreciate it
great to hear from you there's alex from
baltimore with some very very strong
questions and some really interesting
stuff going on um in the background as
well
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian eating a more
plant-based diet is a really great thing
to do for a number of different reasons
and our sponsor just egg is the
delicious plant-based egg you can use it
anywhere you use traditional eggs
because the taste and texture are
identical but
just egg plant-based eggs have the same
amount of protein as traditional eggs i
use it all the time at home
you can make fluffy scrambled eggs you
can make omelettes you can make quiche
frittata crepes
fried rice you should see my fried rice
recipe you can really use it anywhere in
baking or anywhere you would use
traditional eggs when i first tried just
egg
i was surprised that a plant-based egg
could both taste and cook
just like traditional eggs you can get
it at the grocery store instacart amazon
go try it eating a more plant-based diet
is a great decision i do it and i'm not
vegan or vegetarian and just egg makes
it that much more easy and delicious